السلام
عليكم طبعا النهارده يمكن انا جاي اتكلم
معاكم عن حاجه ناس كتيره جدا بتسال نفسها
فيها من وقت للتاني يمكن السؤال اللي
هقوله دلوقتي ناس كتيره ممكن تكون بتسال
برض نفسها السؤال ده في الوقت اللي احنا
فيه هو انا مش هينفع اتعلم لغه
طيب انا عاييز اتعلم لغه بس عايز اتعلمها
ليه اغلب الانترفيو واغلب المكان اي اماكن
بنروح نشتغل فيها بتطلب معانا لغه مع اي
سكيل تانيه او اي شيء تاني بيكون معانا بس
بنلاقي اللغه في بعض الاوقات بل في اغلب
الاوقات هي اهم حاجه وهي اكبر
عائق انك تتكلم لغه مش معناها ان انت
تتكلم زيهم او زي الناس اللي بتتكلم اللغه
نفسها انك تتكلم لغه مقصود بيه انك تقدر
توصل اللي انت عاوز تقوله وتقدر تستقبل
اللي الشخص الثاني عايز يقوله يعني بمثال
بسيط جدا ممكن نقول هي عمليه تبادل رسائل
بينك وبين حد
تاني المشكله لما بنيجي نبص على
ا اللغات عامه او وجود اللغات حوالينا ناس
كتير بتقول طب هي اللغه ازاي هو انا علشان
اتولدت في مكان والمكان ده بيتكلم عربي زي
هنا في مصر اتعلمت اللغه لا يمكن هوريكم
جزء معايا
[موسيقى]
الاول اوبن
صح اوكي النهارده النهارده يمكن
خليت التوك بتاعتي كلها عن ذا ستوري اوف
لانجوج او قصه
اللغه في ناس او بدايه الناس اول ما
بدات نيدر تولز نيدر تولز ههم الناس
البدائيين في ناس اتهمت الاشخاص دول اللي
قدامنا في الصوره ان هم حيوانات او ان هم
حاجه في نظريه التطور الخاصه بالانسان
نفسه بس انا اقدر اقول لكم ان هم مش
حيوانات
هم بني ادمين هم زينا احنا لو بصينا على
الاندر تولز مثلا او الشخص البدائي هنلاقي
ان هم كانوا لابسين لبس كان عندهم جولري
كان عندهم مجوهرات ودي يمكن اتشافت في
الاكسك فيشن اللي كانت بعد كده هو او
الحفريات اللي بعد كده الناس دي كان في
مجتمعات ليها يعني كان في اماكن ليها هم
عايشين فيها اماكن بيصنعوا فيها حاجات
اماكن يعني في حياه شغاله بين الناس ديت
في حياه موجوده تفتكر كل ده حصل من غير
اللغه يعني تفتكر باي طريقه ممكن ده يحصل
من غير وسيله تواصل بين الاشخاص دي وبعض
طيب على اساس ايه انت بتقول ان الناس دي
كان عندها لغه احنا فعلا ما عندناش اي
مصدر يقول ان الناس دي كان عندها لغه
مكتوبه اللغه المكتوبه عامه
ظهورها كان في فتره من 100 سنه يعتبر
بدايه اللغات المكتوبه بدات ان هي تتسجل
وكان قبليها اللغات القديمه اللي هي مش
موجوده يمكن في وقتنا دلوقتي فلازم نعترف
ان اللغه كانت موجوده من اول وقت اتخلق
فيه الانسان اللغه كانت موجوده من اول
مجتمع اتبنى في حياتنا ف اهميه اللغه عامه
زي ما انا قلت لكم في الاول هي عمليه انت
بتدي رساله وبتسمع رساله جايه تاني طيب لو
دخلنا في الموضوع بشكل علمي انا مش هخش في
شكل علمي اكتر على قد ما هتكلم على ازاي
علم لغه بس خليني اول بارت شويه اركز على
الجزء العلمي يمكن في ناس مهتمه بيه ده
شكل اللغه يعني ايه هنا
هووت المنظر بتاع اللغه قدامي هنا هووت هو
عمليه الوصول لفهمك للغه بتوصل ازاي زي ما
احنا شايفين ان اول مكان او اول قناه انت
بتستقبل بيها اللغه هي ودانك يعني اول
مكان بيبدا ان هو يستجمع القوه ديت او
يستجمع الاصوات اللي جايه من حواليك هو
ودانك بيبدا بعد كده بيخش على حاجه اسمها
فيجوال كورتكس الجوال كورتكس لو انا قربت
هنا شويه الجوال كورتكس اللي هي رقم واحد
اناهو ديت بتشوف الشكل اللي هو ريتن او
الشكل المكتوب بعد ما بيبدا العقل
يستقبلها او بيعمل عمليه ريسبشن او عمليه
استقبال ليها بيبدا يخش على الانجر جيرس
ودوت اللي بيحول شكل الكلمه اللي انت
شفتها بيحولها عندك لاتور كود يعني دايما
ناس كتيره جدا لما بتشوف كلمه بتحاول
تنطقها بس مش شرط ان هي تنطقها ببقها مش
بتشوفوا ساعات كلمات كتيره جدا بتحس ان
عقلك بيقوللك الكلمه دي بتحس بصوت الكلمه
نفسها يعني انت لو شفت كلمه بلاك مثلا
مكتوبه لازم تقول بصوتك بلاك لا هتلاقي
عقلك ادالك الاديتور ميم او ادالك الشكل
الصوتي يعني ايه الشكل الصوتي هو عقلك
سبحان الله في الجزء دوت متخصص انه بيحول
اي حاجه مكتوبه لصوت طيب بعد كده بيخش فين
نمبر 3 هنا في حاجه اسمها رينكس ايا
البارت دوت هو اللي بيحاول انه يعدل الكود
شويه بتاع الصوت طيب بعد ما بيعدل كود
الصوت شويه بيبدا يخش على اكبر منطقه مهمه
في تعلم او تكلم او ان انت تفهم لغه هي
منطقه البركه او اللي هي مقدمه المخ
المنطقه ديت لو اقوللكم على الهدف منها هي
ان هي بتحول سبيتش دوت في عمليه موتور او
عمليه زي ما بنتكلم فيها عمليه موتور او
عمليه انجين بيغير الكلام ده كله وفي
الاخر خالص بتروح لمنطقه الموتور كورتكس
او اللي هي المنطقه الاخيره اللي بتديني
فهم للكلمه او للبارت نفسه طبعا عمليه
معقده شويه بس العمليه دي بتحصل في دماغنا
كل نص ثانيه يعني كل ما بتستوعب حاجه من
لغه قدامك لان انت بتتعامل مع لغات كتيره
جدا حواليك سيان عربي سيان انجلش سيان
سبانش سيان اي لغه تانيه بيحصل عندك عمليه
الميكانزم دي بتاع اللغه اللي احنا
شايفينها ويمكن واخده مننا وقت طويل شويه
لو بصينا على الجزء الازرق اللي معانا دوت
ويمكن بقى هبدا اخش في المين بيزك او
المين بوينت بتاع التوك نفسها هنلاقي ان
الجزء الازرق دي الناس اللي بتتكلم لغتين
في الاتحاد الاوروبي او في الدول
الاوروبيه وزي ما احنا شايفين الحجم بيزيد
ده من اهتمام الناس او ده ظاهر من اهتمام
الناس في ان انا لما اتعلم لغه هقدر اتكلم
مع شخص ثاني يعني لو انا من المجر مثلا مش
لازم بس اتكلم هنجاريا او اللغه المجريه
علشان اعيش حياتي او اكمل حياتي
ومقتصرة ان بدا اهتمام الناس في اخر 10
سنين ان هم يضيفوا لغه اين 3 ولو تحت خالص
دي احصائيه من امريكا ان بدا عمليه ان
الناس بتتعلم اكتر من لغه وانا يمكن قصدت
ان انا احط امريكا في الموضوع لان اللي
راح امريكا او شافها وشاف الناس اللي
عايشين هناك هيعرف ان هم اكسل شعب في تعلم
اللغه يعني احنا لو بصينا على الامريكان
كل بيقوللك ان هو انا امريكان انا بتكلم
انجلش اتعلم لغه تانيه ليه العالم كله
بيتكلم اللغه بتاعتي انا ولكن برض بالرغم
من ده لقينا ان عمليه اللغه نفسها بدات
تزيد او عمليه تعلم
اللغات اول شخص معانا النهارده هو المونو
نجوال ده شخص زي الامريكان كده اهو بيتكلم
لغه واحده وغير راضي ان هو يتكلم لغه
ثانيه هو شايف ان هو لما يتكلم لغه وان
اللغه ديت مشهوره جدا زي الصين مثلا لما
عرفوا اهميه الانجلش بداوا يتعلموا انجلش
بس قبل كده كان اللغه الصينيه هي الاهم
عندهم في شخص تاني هو الينجو بعد المون
لينجو في الباينو باينو هو شخص بيتكلم
لغتين مع بعض بعد كده عندنا ترا لينجو شخص
بيتكلم ثلاث
لغات بعد كده تتحول المرحله دي لحاجه
اسمها مالتي لينال مالتي لينجو هو شخص
بيتكلم اكتر من لغه حد اقصى سبع
لغات وبيظهر حاجه في الاخر جديده هي
البولي جلوت ايه بقى موضوع البولي جلوت
بولي جلوت هو شخص بيتكلم سبع لغات وما فوق
يا سبع لغات يعني في انسان هيقدر ان هو
يغير نفسه لسبع شخصيات وهقف يغير مفاهيمه
وطريقه نطقه وطريقه كلامه سبع مرات لا
واكتر من
كده البوليو ازم بدات من فتره كبيره جدا
ويمكن في مصادر كتيره جدا خاصه بالتاريخ
بتقول على البولي جلوت ازم مش هخش فيها
قوي بس عمليه تعدد اللغه او عمليه تعلم
اللغات اصبحت كهوايه عند الناس زي الناس
اللي بتتعلم كمان او بتتعلم ا تعزف على
اداه
معينه ممكن ما يكونش حد ارشد للموضوع دوت
او قال لها انكم لازم تتعلموا كمانجا او
لازم تتعلموا جيتار او لازم تتعلموا ده لا
هي ظهرت عندهم بالفطره لاقوا نفسهم بيحبوا
ان هم يقعدوا مع ناس ويتكلموا معاهم
ولاقوا ان هم قادرين ان يوصلوا مع بعض
الرسائل لبعض ويتكلموا مع بعض فبدات
العمليه عنده تدي لله ريا اكتيفيشن قوي
لما بدا يتعلم انجلش وهو اصلا مصري نزل
وقعد مع ناس ساي في مصر هنا هووت او سافر
جات له الفرصه انه يسافر لما قعد مع الناس
ديت بدا يشوف لا ده انا بتكلم كويس ده هم
فاهميني ده انا فاهمهم فبدات العمليه عنده
يحصل عنده حاجه اسمها سلف ريدين او عمليه
مكافاه نفسيه هو شايف نفسه انا فاهمهم وهم
فاهميني انا مش لاقي صعوبه في التعامل
بيني وبين الناس ديت ف البوليجون نفس اللي
انا بقوله بس بتتقاس على اكتر من لغه طيب
هل دوت فراغ يعني الناس دي عندها وقت كبير
قوي ان هي تعمل ده هو الوقت مهم بس لو
الموضوع وصل ان انت بتتعلم لغات من غير ما
تستخدمها حاجه من الاتنين يا اما هتنساها
يا اما هيحصل لك عمليه احباط انا عمال
اتعلم لغات بس ما بعملش بيها حاجه مافيش
عندي اي
او اي اقدر ان
اعمله طيب مشكلتنا الاهم مش ان انا اعرف
يعني
ايه مش عايز اتكلم 15 لغه مش عايز اتكلم
14 لغه انا عايز اتكلم لغه واحده بس انا
نفسي اتكلمش ككم واحد نفس يتكلم
انجلش يعني عدد مش قليل كم واحد نفسه
يتعلم لغه تانيه بعد
الانجلش الاغلبيه العظمى موجود عايز تعلم
لغه بعد الانجلش
طيب الاشكال نفسها او عمليه تعلم اللغه
بتختلف من شخص لشخص تاني ناس كتيره جدا
بتتعلم بطريقه معينه غير الشخص اللي
جنبيها غير الشخص اللي جنبيها فبيحصل
عمليه تغير في اللغه بس ايه هي ممكن تكون
الصعوبات اللي بتقابلك وانت بتتعلم لغه
اول حاجه عندي وهبدا بيه هي لانج اند في
او عمليه اللغه
والفشل اغلب الناس اللي قابلتها واتكلمت
معايا عن اللغات كانت بتذكر الفشل على
اساس انه هو العائق الاساسي طيب لو رجعنا
كده شويه خلينا نعرف ايه اسباب الفشل في
اللغه ليه انا بفشل في اللغه ليه لما بخش
كورس والكورس بيبقى كبير جدا وغالي جدا
والفيد باك عليه كويسه جدا بس انا بطلع
كاني دخلت يعني كاني دخلت وطلعت من الكورس
ومافيش اي فايده او استفاده بس بسيطه قوي
اهم عوامل الفشل اللي بتحصل وانت بتتعلم
اللغه عاملين اتنين في منهم واحد التث
هتكلم عليه بعديه بس خليني ابدا باهم
اتنين اول حاجه هي
الاحباط الشخص اللي بيتعلم لغه اول حاجه
بتيجي في دماغه هي ان طب انا هعرف اعمل
كده يعني انا في يوم من الايام هقدر اكلم
زي الناس دي خصوصا الناس اللي بتتكلم
دويتش مثلا او الماني يجي مثلا يفتح اوديو
مثلا او يفتح اي حاجه يقول ا wir das und
wir haben hier und gehen wir und se ف د
الشخص اول ما يقوللك يا انا هوصل لكده مش
هوصل فتلاقي عنده عمليه احباط وبيبدا ان
هو ينهي الطريق اصلا من قبل ما يبدا بيه
اول ستيب او اول
خطوه طيب ليه الاحباط بيحصل اصلا هو بس
عشان الاحباط بيحصل ان انا بسمع حاجه وهو
ده الاحباط لا الاحباط عامه بيحصل في
حياتنا كلها انك بتطلع من الكومفورت زون
بتاعتك بتطلع بتحاول تغير حاجه جديده يعني
انت ما ما بتتكلمش دش او بتكلمش الماني
عايز تتكلم دوتش فالمرحله ديت اويب دول او
يعني النقطتين دول بياخدوا منك مجهود كبير
جدا المجهود دوت انك ازاي تقنع نفسك ان
اللي انا بعمله ده
صح خليني اقولك على حاجه برض وانت بتتعلم
لغه وجالك الاحباط شويه حاول تسال نفسك
لات اسئله هعمل ايه لما اتكلم اللغه دي
بطلاقه
هعمل ايه لما اتكلم او لما اتكلم اللغه دي
بطلاقه دلوقتي وبرضو هعمل ايه لما اتكلم
بيها بطلاقه في المستقبل والسؤال الاهم
بقى ايه الفايده اصلا من اللغه دي لازم
تحط عندك موتيفيشن او لازم تحط عندك جول
لازم تحط عندك هدف اساسي انت بتتعلم انجلش
علشان الشغل عندك هدف انت بتتعلم تركش
عشان المسلسلات يعني هدف اوكي وانا بقول
عليه هدف مش قوي لان برض عمليه انك بس
بتتعلم لغه عشان تفهم مسلسل مش هي كل حاجه
انت ليه ما تخدش ان التركي عايز تتعلمه
عشان نفسك تسافر تركيا فتنزل تقعد مع
الناس فتتكلم هي دي الجايزه اللي بتاخدها
لما بتتعلم اي لغه ان الناس تفهمك وانت
تفهم الناس مش ان انت بس تتعلم اللغه اه
لا انا بتكلم تركش طب تعلمت تركش منين لا
مسلسل كان بيجي عندنا بس قعد مع لاث سنين
فانا لقطت كا حاجه وده اللي بيحصل لا تعلم
اللغه مش بيزكس تعلم اللغه مش حاجات يعني
فمنت تاخدها واقول كده انتهى لا ده البي
اللي انت بتتعلمها سيان المصدر بتاعها ايه
هي اساس ليك انك تكمل بعد كده اساس ليك ان
هي تشجعك في حاجه زي
كده الحاجه التانيه لجيم حاول تنظم وقتك
وانت بتتعلم اللغه انت الازر لنفسك انت
اللي بتركز على الاك اللي بتعمله لنفسك
حاول ما تخليش فكره ان الوقت نفسه بيضيع
منك لا انت اللي هتقدر تنظم حاجه زي كده
حاجه تانيه لانجوج اند ايج انت عمرك مش
عقبه قدامك ما تقولش ان الشخص الصغير او
الشخص اللي هو اقل في السن الشخص دوت
هيتعلم اللغه احسن مني ممكن تحصل في حاله
ان هو يتولد في دوله تانيه ولكن الاهم
عندك انت دلوقتي عندك تارجت الطفل م عندوش
التارجت ده م عندوش الهدف نفسه اللي هو
هيطلع
وهيتكلف تعلمه لا هو بياخد فكره ان بتعلم
اللغه عشان انا بس مجبر عليها من المدرسه
او من الناس اللي حواليا فانا بتكلم اللغه
لكن انت كشخص بالغ قادر تحدد هدفك في تعلم
اللغه تاني حاجه لانجوج اند سوسايتي حاول
دايما تخلي سوسايتي اللي حواليك بيتكلم
اللغه اللي انت بتتعلمها مش هقوللك تخلي
الناس نفسها تتكلم اللغه دي ازاي بس انا
هقول لك ان انت تحاول تخلي كل حاجه حواليك
بتتكلم اللغه دي زي الراديو زي الانترنت
زي الموبايل معلش انا طولت عليكم النهارده
بس انا كانس اقعد معاكم اكتر من
كده خلاص صح يلا ف ان شاء الله اقابلكم
تاني في توكس تانيه
[تصفيق]
شكرا